There's no denying 2016 was a fantastic year
for video games, but 2017 is shaping up to
be even better.
Here's a sneak peek at the top video games
of 2017.
Winter
The year kicks off in epic fashion with the
January release of the hotly anticipated Resident
Evil 7, the latest entry in the franchise
which has been the industry standard in horror
for over two decades.
And things don't slow down from there.
Winter also finally brings gamers For Honor,
which has been teased for seemingly an eternity
at this point.
Then there's also the bizarre future dystopia
Horizon Zero Dawn and the latest Tom Clancy
game, Ghost Recon Wildlands.
Plus real time strategy fans get a special
treat with the release of Halo Wars 2, while
fans of the superhero fighting game Injustice
finally get a sequel as well.
But all of that is overshadowed by one of
the most hotly anticipated games of the year,
Mass Effect: Andromeda, which is set to blow
minds in March as the series leaves Commander
Shepard and the entire Milky Way behind for
a galaxy full of new characters, new aliens,
and new moral conundrums sure to test even
the bravest of souls.
Heck yeah!
Spring
Fans of the Persona series have waited nearly
nine years for the next official installment
to be released, but that wait will finally
end in April when Persona 5 hits consoles
with the story a new group of students at
Shujin High School who band together to face
down the shadowy group known as the Phantom
Thieves of Hearts.
And Persona isn't the only series to get a
sequel in Spring.
Outlast II promises a new round of survival
horror and nightmare inducing creepiness,
while Tekken 7 is no doubt full of people
punching each other and shouting catchphrases.
Gwent, meanwhile, takes the game-within-a-game
from the Witcher franchise and gives it the
full spotlight in a Hearthstone-style collectible
card game with a single-player campaign.
Perhaps the most intriguing title of the Spring,
though, is Tacoma.
Brought to you by the same minds who created
the surprise hit Gone Home, Tacoma takes that
game's investigative mystery feel and moves
it to the claustrophobic interior of a derelict
space station — where something has definitely
gone wrong.
Players have to try and uncover the mystery
of what happened to the crew.
Honestly?
It's so creepy already, we're not sure we
even want to know.
Summer and Fall
Considering the gaming industry is full of
delays and outright cancellations, it's no
wonder studios are hesitant to give their
games firm release dates too far in advance.
But while we don't know for sure when these
games are going to come out, here are some
of the other titles you should be able to
play sometime in 2017.
Inspired by old Mickey Mouse cartoons, Cuphead
has captured the imagination of retro gamers
and sidescroller fans everywhere.
Rumor has it the designers are just putting
the final touches on co-op mode, so no further
delays are anticipated.
Besides Cuphead, there are a handful of other
new intellectual properties to keep an eye
on this year.
Scalebound is an epic third-person action
game where you get to control a freaking dragon…
...which is always cool.
Days Gone features more apocalyptic survival
fare, only this time in one of our nation's
national parks, so that's, y'know, nice.
And Detroit: Become Human fights back against
urban decline with a futuristic neo-noir story
about androids, where every choice has major
ramifications for the storyline.
If sequels are more your thing, though, don't
worry, because 2017 has a metric ton of returning
franchises, starting with God of War.
Yes, Kratos is back in a story which sees
the older and more grizzled warrior taking
on a new challenge: osteoporosis.
"I've fallen and I can't get up."
Ah-hah, no.
Just kidding, he's fighting the Norse gods
and monsters this time.
There are plenty of other fan favorite franchises
making a comeback in 2017.
Shenmue 3 makes its long awaited return after
getting crowdfunded on Kickstarter.
Legend of Zelda: Breath of the Wild takes
the Nintendo classic and adds a dash of
modern gameplay.
Dead Island 2 moves the zombie survival game
to Los Angeles and focuses on slapstick multiplayer
gameplay.
Quake Champions is the latest first-person-shooter
arena showdown.
Agents of Mayhem is a Saints Row third person
shooter spin-off revolving around an anti-terrorist
organization.
Crackdown 3 features an open world sandbox
and the ability to level civilizations with
godlike powers.
Then there's also a Spider-Man game coming
from the developers of Ratchet & Clank, which
will no doubt somehow tie in to the release
of the summer film blockbuster Spider-Man:
Homecoming.
And then there's Super Mario Switch, a game
so secret, we don't even know the actual title
yet.
But wait!
That's not all.
Two of the biggest releases of the year are
also sequels.
South Park: The Fractured But Whole builds
on the surprisingly great RPG elements of
South Park: The Stick of Truth to deliver
an even broader and more detailed world, this
time parodying the superhero genre.
And the mere announcement that there would
be a Red Dead Redemption 2 was enough to rocket
the game to the top of everyone's wish list
for next Christmas.
Here's hoping Santa has a huge sleigh, because
he's going to need it to carry all these great
games.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!